all right the Veck why don't we start
with what you guys do and then we'll
rewind to before you even did YC yes
sure
some vivent one of the founders and CEO
of hacker ranked our mission at hacker
rank is to match every developer to the
right job with the underlying driver
being skill I mean so resumes are just a
very poor correlation to skill so that's
how we got started the way what we do as
a product as a developer you could come
on to hacker and to practice and improve
your skills across different dimensions
but that's algorithms or artificial
intelligence or data based skills and
when you're applying to a company
instead of going through the traditional
route of uploading a resume and it's
mostly going to be a black hole you take
a company's coding challenge so if you
want to play the where B and B you take
an airbnb scoring challenge if you want
to play the VM where you take a VM
where's coding challenge and if you have
the required skills basically we
automate the whole code and give you a
report then you get called in for an
interview so it's great for developers
because it's a merit-based process is
great for companies because now you're
able to attract the right developers for
their interview process and what might
one of those challenges look like for
instance Airbnb are we being put into
the code base in any way what would it
look like yeah I think that it vaidhi so
we've given we built a platform where
it's super custom for companies to go
ahead and create so you could have a
simple problem solving challenge to
something close to a real world where
you could have a you could give an
access to our github repo okay and
people can go ahead and modify the code
fix a bug on your own your rep o to go
ahead and do it so there's a wide range
of problems that you could give on the
platform okay gotcha so you guys haven't
always been doing this correct in his in
its exact instantiation yeah so let's go
backwards yeah before YC what were you
working on yeah sure
so socati is my co-founder right bla we
we knew each other from college we used
to do a bunch of things together in
college and we started we started the
company technically we quit our jobs I
used to work at Amazon as a developer
before this where I did a lot of
technical interviews which is kind of
way
I saw the problem yeah you know the
resumes were not a good correlation to
skills so we quit our job the the way we
started to do the we thought that the
way to solve this problem of resumes not
correlating skills was to help prepare
students for their interviews so we
start an interview street that was our
first version and what it did was mock
interviews so let's say you had an
interview call with Amazon or Google
next week you could come onto our site
and attend a mock interview with either
somebody from Amazon or somebody an X
Amazon person who can give you a
walkthrough of here are the things we'll
do a mock interview and give you what
what are the ideas that you need improve
where do you stand on all of those
things and the students would be paying
these people for their time that's right
okay so it's gonna be you know it's
gonna be hard for people to comprehend
the value here in the US because we were
doing it in India but we were charging
350 rupees Indian currency for from the
student and 200 and we used to pay 250
rupees to the to the interviewer so 100
rupees goes to our pocket right so you
could almost imagine that to be
something on the lines of I mean
technically it's six dollars and five
dollars yeah but but as you mean you
earn different amounts you could say a
student would pay $200 something like
that and an interview will get about a
hundred and fifty dollars okay so then
if you if you then think about it in
that way it's it was pretty expensive
for students and we didn't have any good
payment gateways or anything of that in
India so we used to set up campus
ambassadors and different colleges and
Hadi and I used to do a trip every month
to visit all of these colleges to
collect money from these campus
ambassador cash yeah so our accounting
was all pretty pretty funny and and from
an interviewer perspective two hundred
fifty two peas or like $150 or something
on those lines here is not very is not
enticing all right if I have to spend an
hour of my time doing a mock interview
and giving you feedback is it worth it
so we I still have the Excel
which projects us to make I think
somewhere on the lines of a hundred
million dollars or hundred crores
whatever it's like fifty million dollars
and along those lines yeah in the
beginning yeah I think we made about
four thousand rupees or maybe about
that's like I equivalent of a hundred
dollars here okay after a year or a year
and a half so clearly you could just
drag the cells in the excel in whatever
way you want and get the numbers but
it's very hard to execute so that failed
I mean we had a lot of lessons that we
learned from that most importantly I
mean the students didn't have cash there
was a lot of scheduling and I think one
of the things that YC stresses on the
most I wish we had actually done YC at
that point I think this was done by Paul
bouquet make something that hundred
users really love versus making thousand
people or ten thousand people sort of
okay like okay I think we should have
focused on you know what we're just
going to focus on these two companies
mock interviews right versus any tech
company anywhere in the world and we
were scrambling for interviewers from
Amazon Google Microsoft follower we
should just focus you know what these
are the three companies have been gonna
focus if you want to get a job here you
can come into and make it really happy
and then figure out a way to scale
looking back yeah of course but did
people like the product yeah whenever
people did the interviews they really
liked it in fact there was there were a
lot of really interesting testimonials
of people who actually attended the
interviews got their job they knew what
what are some of the areas that they
need to improve they need to prepare and
all of those things yeah that's great
yeah I mean I remember all the
interviews I did during college like if
I could have just gotten the email of
someone yeah one of these companies it
would have been invaluable to me we used
to do that sort of informally in college
right when we were in the final year of
college we used to train people for sort
of mock interviews and others so this
was more like an extension yeah why
can't he do this on an over the web
across everyone interesting so you
weren't necessarily off the mark around
finding something that people really
liked but you found that you kind of hit
a ceiling somewhere and it was it wasn't
very focused either so there were a lot
of there were different cohorts of
people and some of them were students
some of them were
were a couple of years into their work
experience okay and some of them wanted
to do technical interviews some of them
wanted to do instead of a automobile
interview and then we had to go ahead
and scramble and figure out can we get
somebody from the automobile division to
come and take the interview we had no
contact so we had to figure out a way to
scramble through LinkedIn and Facebook I
think it was it was sort of okay but it
really taught us to just stay strong
yeah okay and so at what point do you
decide you like you know what we have to
change this this isn't working
yeah it's probably about 18 months well
we had apply to YC or you did we'd have
played a Y Combinator with this idea of
course we got turned down then we I
think it was about 1215 months something
on those lines when I mean clearly this
wasn't going anywhere the Excel was
completely off the trajectory of the
Excel graph and where we were and then
we switched our business model or idea
there's something different okay so
there is a big trend or there is still
present in India which is once you
graduate you have to do your masters in
a school here oh it's huge I mean pretty
much you know I don't know 80 90 percent
of people would attempt their GRE which
is your standard way of getting here
your TOEFL they will prepare their
statement of purpose they will do all of
those and the application form is pretty
expensive right and so you could only
apply to maybe five or six universities
because it was so expensive
I couldn't just you couldn't just apply
to all the schools in the US so what we
did was we connected people who were
already studying in these schools who
can review your statement of purpose
your resume and tell you if you had a
chance to come here to apply to the
school okay so that was our pivot they
actually took off a bit but then after
three months or so the traffic was down
to zero turns out you can only apply
twice a year so we didn't know what to
do for the rest of the year we don't
actually apply to YC even with this idea
there you go so I think this whole thing
about mock interviews applying helping
people apply for the Masters
maybe your and a half to two something
on those lines okay that that we worked
on yeah okay and then what sparked you
to start working on where you are now
yeah well we're close to bankrupt so
there was a real need and you know of
course we had really good jobs and
Amazon was was a great was a great
company to where were you in India
working on all of this is in India okay
and so then we realized okay so just a
posse really okay how are you making the
connections of people here if you were
based in India sure so what we did was
we used to take the directory of people
from our school okay who went ahead and
did masters at all of these different
universities and who are working in
different companies so we used to go
through the directory keep calling
people email them hey are you interested
we are from Yard we are from the same
university that University touch in to
get them on board so it was just friends
networks second degree and I used to I
used to make I don't know 50 calls every
day Wow to get this going okay and just
for context for me people from India
want to do a master's here because it's
a like a gateway to getting a job here
or what I don't know how it started
maybe it was just I think I I think it
is it's sort of a checkbox okay I'm not
sure this changed now but it was
definitely I mean I graduated eight
years back it was or nine years back it
was definitely a pride okay you know
what I'm going to do my masters here and
and there's of course some glamour
associated with the great American Dream
coming here and getting working in this
in the Silicon Valley Silicon Valley is
sort of this mythical place for all
Technology developers to be here okay so
it was more like a checkbox I still
think it is the case that you you would
have to apply if you had a good GPS and
if you had good grades the question is
why aren't you going why are you flying
for a masters that's funny even among
they're like the very talented smart
kids going to great schools in India
yeah sure I think you're playing for
your masters why aren't you doing your
PhD here in one oh and Carnegie
or Stanford or Purdue and there are a
lot of actually I my hottie and I might
actually be the odd man out cuz you
didn't do it yeah we didn't anyway yes
and I'm happy because I'd applied to six
school I was so dejected when the school
held me down but in hindsight it's great
right I don't think would have started
the company bad come here no probably
not
this is a conservative move yes and you
have to once you graduate you'd have to
get a job because you have to pay back
the loan which is pretty big so you do
two years of masters then you do two to
three years of working in different
companies to pay back the loan and
there's all of these visa things and by
the time you you want to start you're
already
I don't know close to five six years
invested in this that's really common
and the friction to or the inertia to go
ahead and start another company when
you're happy working at Amazon or Google
it's gonna be hard yeah yeah definitely
and so okay so you're basically out of
money yeah we're still close to bankrupt
yeah yeah and and yeah so we had we had
a clear choice which is we could go back
and get a job I think we could have got
that but something we just wanted to
keep going we just wanted to try try
this out once more and I have no idea
what kept us going at that point in time
and there was some conversation we were
just walking it on which was it sounds
obvious if you have to make money you
have to sell something to people who
have money there's no way you're gonna
make any money we were selling to
students and others were already in
whatever they had called student debt
and they had very little money so that's
when we said hey can we invert this
which is can we build a product for
companies to help them identify the
right developers based on our skills of
course we didn't have the mission
written down like match every developer
to the right job but looking back I
think that was the core of every
decision that we made and and and we
felt you know we'll still stay true to
our core because it doesn't it's mock
interviews is one way of doing this but
if you actually give a platform that can
enable developers from it doesn't matter
what school
go to which company you went but you
have a chance to showcase your skills
and get the dream job that you want then
that's great you know we should build a
platform for that you know that's what
we got started and that got the early
attraction so that was a third time we
apply the YC and yeah why is he called
at that time all right
and was it because you were showing
significant growth at the time or the
idea was just working out I mean I don't
know I I definitely didn't want to ask
why did why are you guys this is a
mistake sure so that was our first trip
to the US yeah so and and and we had
some struggles there as well hari my
co-founder couldn't get his visa to come
here and I still think it's the stance
of YC but YC cares about co-founders a
lot and so so I got my visa how do you
couldn't get and so I flew in here just
for the 10 minute interview this was
yeah six years back and fortunately we
got in and I remember you know I think I
think there was a panel of interviews it
was PG Sam hard Jessica and Paul bouquet
there was five people doing me okay and
you know that's the foot I landed in the
morning in the evening was the YC
because I couldn't get my visa on time
over the last day of interview yes day
of interviews only the last one like
yeah yeah the last one as well could it
be and then you you see all these five
people is a creator of gmail you're
obviously a little bit stressed and then
you don't have a co-founder and PG asta
where is your co-founders visa but it
was a it was a good intense ten minute
and frankly I didn't think we'll get
into YC so I was and maybe it worked to
our advantage because I was just
completely open and honest about
everything because I didn't I didn't
fake any of my answers or try to impress
them look this is the problem I'd really
want to come here and go ahead and do
this and it probably worked out our
advantage interesting yeah I mean so
what you were working on before has this
separate difficulty in the application
because you have to educate someone
about what it's like in India versus
here yeah where we have the exact same
problem of like oh we're this company we
have all these jobs yeah we don't have
enough engineers like yeah let's sort
this out yeah yeah I think there is a
there is an imminent
way things I mean yeah you're right the
environment is different I mean I
remember I used P G's so I didn't have
so I used to sit in the Pioneer way
office white-dominated office for most
by actually our first office was right
opposite to the YC pioneerof yeah yeah
it was a rethink TBS old office okay
which we actually took so it was right
opposite so I used to be in Y Combinator
for most part I remember I took P G's
charger Mac charger by mistake oh and
this was the second day or the third day
and I was I was I was so kind of I
didn't know what to do because oh my god
what is Fiji gonna think and then I
started emailing I'm really really sorry
charger he said no problem just keep it
just keep it there tomorrow and I said
okay are you gonna come in tomorrow and
he said he's not gonna come in tomorrow
I because the the way at least I was
brought up and for most part in India is
if you keep a charger or if you keep the
Amazon box right outside the door
somebody's gonna take it away right and
even the even the tiny things and then I
had to you have to learn about how the
environment is different how people talk
how people react to it in the dinner
time here is 6:30 so I remember sending
a calendar and invite for dinner to to a
person that I want to recruit for 9:00
p.m. and he said that's kind of my
bedtime so I can meet you in nightly
yeah so there are all of these things
that you have to learn and it's not just
the macro part of the developer how it
works but even the tiny things about how
you interact how you work with people
and all of those things you have to
learn yes yeah has that been
incorporated into your product because
you know I imagine you have all these
international people applying to US
companies yeah how do you help educate
them on the cultural norms yeah no it is
it is a really good question because
right from how you sort of how the the
types of sentences or words that you use
varies quite a bit between what you
would say to somebody in Asia what you
would say somebody to you in UK and what
we would say somebody here so all of
those nuances we need to take care of
because you you want there is a there is
a different culture
aspect on how you sell how you talk how
you get people going here it's really
difficult how long does it take you in
particularly I think it's a forever
learning I don't think I've ever facted
it I've got in my dinnertime now at 7
p.m.
yeah shifted a little but but I think
it's a constant learning I don't think I
don't think it's ever gonna stop yeah my
friend moved to India for a couple years
and he explained the exact thing
opposite yeah yeah it was tough for him
yeah I mean every I mean it's it's just
the way you you grow up is different I
mean that there's nothing there's
nothing that's right or wrong it's just
different and you have to get used to it
and I remember peih-gee and sam
correcting me from everything to even
the tiny once its own india you would
probably say programmer you would add
the a at the end but here people will
not be able to follow it's programmer so
if you have to say and when I when I was
doing my demo day pitches all of these
little things mattered because it was
just a five minute pitch or no I think
it was a two minute or a five minute
pitch for the demo day and every little
thing matters a lot because when you're
talking to investors so it's not just
the accent but how you talk how you
schedule meetings how you follow up and
everything is different yeah
demo day stuff universally because yeah
I mean you're pitching a master group I
think you said your batch was like 60 or
70 I think I think our batch was 63 or
65 yeah and so that's enough companies
or one to just fall into like monotony
but but interesting I really enjoyed it
because I've never been exposed to
exposed to such a large group of
investors and I I was I couldn't even
sleep the previously I was looking
forward to it look I wanted a pitch and
get get a CD say going so I I frankly
enjoyed it I was looking forward to it
that's very cool
so you raise money after YC yeah and
you're committed you're like okay we're
gonna stay in California at this point
yeah I mean after I came here to
Mountain View and I don't know maybe
that's that's just partially the reason
the first city
well I technically landed in San
Francisco but immediately cap and came
to Mountain View it was I I just
I think everything everything looked
great for for most part I mean the right
from the kind of the people that you
interact with the advice that you get
the weather the food sort of the perfect
mix for me of coming from India
you had the weather similar to Bangalore
and the food similar to Bangalore and
Chennai and then you had all the people
that that I really wanted to talk and
get advice from in terms of building a
company so it was the perfect mix at
least for me so I I was very much
determined to stay here and build a
company man what was that like you know
flying here and then seeing all the
people who you like you read their blog
post ug is an easy example yeah what was
that experience like yeah it was it was
kind of surreal I I didn't know it was
as I said I I thought I was going to
just stammer and and flunk the interview
but like I mentioned I didn't think we'd
get it actually we were the first Indian
based company to get into Y Combinator
really yeah and so that was another
quote unquote
I don't know if it helped or didn't help
because we thought okay they've never
chosen a computing based company so our
odds are low that really helped because
I was just completely free and open but
it was great it was great to meet all of
the all of the people that you admire
far off from reading your blog post or
Twitter or watching their videos yeah
and what were your what were your
greatest learnings from the experience
from YC yeah
I think the the intensity was very very
high because there was a there was a
dinner every week and you I mean each I
I noticed that each founder had their
own set of people that they interact
with of course I interact with a lot of
them but you you talk to a few people in
and then you hear their updates every
week that's and you want to push harder
and you have a you have a fixed deadline
three months down three months you have
a demo day which you have to go and
present to investors so you have a fixed
demo fixed timeline to you to make sure
that you have a good prototype you could
possibly paying customers to go ahead
and do it and I think the bar is
continue to increase right at every demo
day so I think the intensity I think the
learning is I still think Hadi and I
have that intensity for most part which
is good Wow how do you keep it up cuz
people talk about this all the time
they're like it's so cool having a
cohort that you can kind of benchmark
yourself against yeah but once you're
out you're kind of out yeah I don't know
maybe we're just uh its DNA or we're
just consistently hungry to win but I
think the challenge is can you extend
that across the entire company I don't
think we've done that we've done an okay
job at that right so I think that's
something that we still need to get
better at that's a challenge so sort of
fast-forward massively yeah now yeah the
reason we started talking about doing
the podcast in general yeah was that you
guys released this developer skills
report yeah so just for folks who
haven't seen it can you explain it yeah
sure so we have a developer community
that's over
I think it's 3.4 million as of as of
last week that's slightly over 10% of
the world's developer population who
come who come to hacker and to solve
challenges to practice their skills and
get better and one of the things that we
wanted to do was to learn more about our
developers so we sent a survey actually
it had 40 questions there's a lot of
debate you know will develop firstly
will develop the survey and then you're
sending a survey to developers with 40
questions something on the others lines
what are the odds that somebody is
actually going to fill this so we sent
this to a million of our
developers whoa it was amazing we got
close to 40,000 people complete the
survey that was huge
I think Stack Overflow had 60,000 and
they have 20 million developers or so so
if you compare the ratio the engagement
and how many people completed survey was
giant and hopefully we get it we we can
beat stack overflows number next year
yeah what was your like email subject
line how'd you get so many people to
convert that's a good question and we
did a B test but maybe mykola our
marketing team Radhika they might have a
better idea on on what was the subject
line but we did a/b test yeah a few
things and we we also tested on the
timing you know when to send to which
cohort depending on the country
depending on the geography and all of
you because you're fairly distributed
right in terms of user base yeah so
we're maybe it's about 26 to 28 percent
in North America okay about 40 years
percent plus in Asia is your Pacific and
then you're talking about 15 to 20
percent in the UK in the remaining
invest yeah okay so for each of the GOS
we also optimize the subject line when
to send them and how do we actually
position this so we did a bunch of
things on those lines was it dialed in
for language or all in English I know it
was all in English okay yeah I don't
think we changed any language so the
questions were waiting from when did you
learn to code to what do you look for
when you're switching for a job or if
you're hiding manager what do you look
for in a candidate so we had a wide
variety of questions and some really
really interesting insights so we had we
engaged a firm who could parse the data
who could do real analysis on this and
we're also likely going to put this up
on our website for all of our developers
to go ahead and do the analysis with our
raw data so something might happen maybe
in the next couple of quarters yeah it
was it was a really interesting insights
and we published this earlier this year
yeah we got over half a million
developers to read the survey I think
this was a this was a huge milestone and
a and exceeded kind of at least my
expectations in both the quality of the
content the design
the reception that we got and of course
there's podcast with a day so it
exceeded my expectations in all
dimensions so alright I guess the most
important question is what programming
language is the most popular I think it
varies across different industries and
you know for I think the one that people
want to learn a lot is Python and the
one that's starting to get a lot more
popular as go but it there are but it
varies across different industries from
what financial services want for this
fast-growing internet companies want
versus retail just all of these
companies are transforming into software
comprise so each of them have a
different variation of it ok
it's so for a developer who's curious
and sees the survey yeah do you kind of
funnel them through a flow on your site
like if you're interested in getting
into banking you ought to be learning
yes yeah question so we are trying to do
with the rivers which is what what do
you want to learn what language and
skills do you want to learn and then
we'll help you recommend you know what
weird
where can you most fit where do you see
where do where as hacker banks see you
the best fit or the best job for you
based on all the data that we've
collected ok gotcha
so let's go through some of the facts in
the fun facts oh sure I saw there were
in the beginning of the report it's a
lot of stuff about age yeah so when when
did people start learning out a program
when does it all begin yeah I mean I
think the the most the fun insight was
one in every four developers learn to
code before they learn to drive yeah
that was a that was a really interesting
insight that we were able to get and and
it's it's not super surprising for me as
a developer but when when we announced
this it was it was just I think it was
the most popular insider we even started
printing t-shirts and in our company and
that was that was there was an
interesting one and it just shows the
fact that self learning is starting to
become big people are learning on their
own
you don't necessarily need to go to a
particular school to do to your
four-year degree and then understand how
to code or how to build applications and
it's just going to I think over if you
just extrapolate the trend line I think
this will be two and four or three and
four developers will learn to code
before they drive in the next decade or
so
yeah and did you collect any data around
boot camps coding boot camps yeah we did
we did collect I think the we collected
data on how much the hiding managers are
others valued the boot camps and kind of
learning it was mixed to be frank I
think there were certain hiding managers
who value did a lot in certain hiring
managers who did okay and my guess is
this probably depends on the quality of
the boot camp right I mean there are a
lot of them who there are there are you
know set of boot camps who say you know
what come here doesn't matter whether
you know how to code or not I'll help
you become a great yeah
valleca in 90 days I mean it's that's
not how it works right
and it almost seems like a negative
signal for sometimes which is oh you
didn't know how to code ninety days
before and now you're claiming that
you're a react expert you know that that
puts me off so I think it depends upon
the quality of boot camps and then then
on the other extreme you have this
school which I was personally really
impressed by it's called 42 okay it's a
school actually PG tweeted about it it's
reference that's right they just opened
that they just opened just opened
another one in Fremont where I had a
chance to visit where it's you you of
course have to take a minimum level of
coding proficiency challenge or a test
yeah and then you are allowed to explore
whatever types of computer science
topics that you really like and then
figure out which one you have a natural
attraction or a passion for whether it's
security or machine learning or a
front-end developer and then continue to
get better at at that and then will help
you connect to the right job so that
that seemed to be a different approach
but it's very different right because if
I understand it correctly they're giving
people room and board that's good and
it's like a huge long it's free yeah and
it's over the course of years yes right
right yeah so yeah it is it is it is
very different be interesting to see how
that experiment works because I think it
was started by a really big billionaire
in in France or something he just wants
to help the world so I'm not sure how
how it might work from a business value
proposition but at least in terms of net
improvement to the world to create more
developers
and to help improve technology I think
that's a that's a great start yeah so I
think I think that's why the boot camps
had a mixed one from the hiding managers
at least okay and then what are what are
the differences between you know
startups hiring and big you know like
Amazon type companies yeah I think the
one common thing was everybody stressed
on the importance of problem solving
skills irrespective of the you word a
smaller company or a bigger company and
others and the one thing that the
startups or the execs cared about the
most because at least in a start-up you
maybe you might have a recruiter or not
but most likely you're doing the
recruiting on your own they care more
about your contributions or your open
source contribution so your profiles our
portfolio much more than what a large
company cared about but at the heart of
it people wanted strong problem solvers
and in also one of the things that was
there was present in the survey was how
you wanted to dive in deeper on the
knowledge of that particular stack at
least for a startup because of course
you have very low or pretty much no
bandwidth to train somebody on the new
stack that you're working on versus a
large company where you have a little
more bandwidth to go ahead and train so
you're okay with the generalist who can
come and learn a new language versus in
a startup I like you to know the
particular language or the stack before
you come in so those were some of the
nuances of the differences that you can
see between a startup at a large company
so in terms of structuring a job
offering to someone or rather just like
a job posting yeah what are the things
that end up appealing to developers yeah
I mean this was very interesting because
I assumed differently and of course
always data over here and one of the
things that we learned was how work-life
balance beats all of the different perks
that people offer whether that's free
food or or we have a ping-pong
tournament every week things along those
lines and then we I actually didn't
believe this data firstly so we I wanted
to do another survey for people who did
the work life balance who actually opted
in what would you really mean by worked
and what we learned was a lot of
developers have their own projects that
they want to learn that they want to
build on the side and the environment
that you're working should give a good
amount of balance and probably even
support if you can do on the things that
they're learning on the site or the
building on the side versus what you're
doing for the company yeah so that was
that was kind of a interesting insight
about work-life balance and one of the
things that you know I'd like to do what
hacker and we're still discussing on how
do you position this in the right ways
if you have any of the site projects
that you're working on yeah we'll fund
the infrastructure cost for that so it's
we're still figuring out how do you
position this how do you how do you give
this away and I'm pretty sure after
people hear this podcast ain't gonna
email you stuff but that's one way of
helping or encouraging people to do that
as well Oh interesting and so what are
the other ways that companies signal
that they have that work-life balance
figure it out or is it just like folks
come in for the interview they get a
sense for it and then they say yes or no
yeah that is one but but I also think if
you're actively contributing to open
source whether that's I mean for example
we are improving a lot of the open
source code editors there that are there
right now we've not done a great job in
letting the world know about all the
improvements that we've been we've been
doing but that's one way and of course
interviews helped a lot in understanding
more about the developer culture okay
and do you guys have any rules around
working on side projects because I know
that like at larger tech companies there
are totally issues and like you know I
don't think they really flex that muscle
very often and ever yeah but yeah you
know like companies like Apple are
infamous for not letting people do side
price yeah yeah I mean that's probably
one of the advantages when you're small
which is I mean as I don't think we have
any tools I don't think we should put
any rules because it's just freedom or
creativity to go ahead and do it and
frankly if it's gonna be conflicting
with your with your core idea and you're
scared about it maybe you should take
the developers idea and implement it
it's better or otherwise you could just
you don't need to be scared and you can
just have the developer work on the
projects that they want so I know I
don't think we should put in use but I
mean a large company like Apple or
Amazon or Google will will need to put
in constraints yeah yeah all the Google
hack this by putting a 20% rule where
you could 20% of the time you can work
on your projects I think that's how
Gmail was born where I think Paul book
he worked on is 20% free time to build
Gmail so that's how they hack it it's
not really technically a side project
that you do outside you use all the
Google infrastructure and libraries and
eventually contribute to Google so
that's one way you could try and do it
interested what else is uh what else is
attractive to a developer yeah and the
other thing that we that we had and the
survey was really on continuous learning
I think there are just there are just so
many new things that come up new layers
of abstraction right which is which is
obviously very enticing for a developer
new frameworks I mean there's a
framework in for Java 7 launched every
month or every two months which is kind
of driving crazy because you just have
to keep migrating from one over to the
other and that the other thing was
continuous learning can I learn new
things can I learn how to how to get
better so that that is a forever
learning attitude or culture what else
did you learn about how developers are
actually educating themselves so
obviously some percentage are going to
boot camps some are doing CS what is
everyone else yeah it's it was really
interesting even though you had a CS
degree a lot of developers said they
actually learned a lot from YouTube
works are sites like hacker rank it's
not a plug for hacker rank even though I
think the title might say this or
whatever but but that was really
interesting because that's that's a new
that's gonna change it's a paradigm
shift right now because if you look 10
years back and then paradigm shift in
recruiting because if you look 10 years
back you're going to use GPAs and
universities and the companies that you
worked at as proxies yeah but now the
proxies are changing right it doesn't
matter if you went to a grade schooler
and
great GPA if you if you learned on your
own and build a lot of things on your
own it's that is what is needed that's
all is enough so the way that you look
for in a candidate who do you look for
how to assess how do you get people in
the door and how do you remove biases
that's been there for not 10 years
that's been there for a hundred years or
do you go to this school or did he work
in this get company how do you remove
this those bias and truly focus on the
skill I mean it's a lot of work it's
going to but that's a big paradigm shift
and it's a very good and healthy trend
if more developers can learn on their
own for free you don't have to pay a
hundred thousand dollars for tuition
it's it's just good overall for the
world to do that interesting and so how
would someone stand out like what are
the kinds of projects that end up
appealing to a company because I know if
you do a lot of these like boot camps
like great you made your own CMS like so
did ten thousand other people yeah did
you get any insight as to you know when
someone does care about these projects
what are the kinds of projects that
appeal to companies yeah I think I think
it's hard to I think there's one part of
it which is your sort of motivation or
your drive which can really come through
which is I mean if you look at you right
if you just [ __ ] rapa repo and made
some made a couple of edits in one file
it really doesn't you can't claim that
you actually done contributed
open-source or anything but I think one
is one is definitely indicates a drive
the second is also and which is probably
hard to just look at a hacker and
profile or a or a github about any of
the profiles and you can't just look and
figure it out is the depth of thinking
and what are all the things that this
developer wants to do more and that's
something probably you can get from the
interview but the bigger question really
is would you be willing to bring this
person on-site and go through the
interview process based on their skills
and not on their pedigree and it sounds
obvious but we're trying to educate our
customers and everybody or hiring
developers this is the right way to go
and we're sort of leading and pushing
the movement for this and hopefully we
can be successful at
yeah cool and and how does this affect a
situation where you're hiring remote
developers are there any other
particular cues that you pay attention
to well yeah what it work yeah I think I
think the communication aspect is always
always a big deal how do you how do you
get everybody in sync I think some of
the companies have done an amazing job
gitlab is a YC company I talked to their
CEO and it's fully remote it's crazy
how then it's just shows how much effort
that you need to put in to make sure
that that people are in sync with each
other I do think in and you're seeing
this happen a lot get lab is just an
example but I know a lot of others a lot
of other companies for starting to do is
I think I think the future would be an
ability for you to build out engineering
teams wherever you want and not just
restrict yourself to the Bay Area and
and a good common connective tissue that
makes sure that things don't break
because of bad communication or because
of time zone differences and others I
think that's that's where the world is
going to move and which means ability to
know their skills and how they can
contribute when when you're not in the
office and all of the others is going to
play a very very important part like
ability do you understand both of this
at a deeper level it's gonna play an
important role yeah and have you guys
conjectured or or started working on
anything that might be able to test
someone's like efficacy as a remote
developer because it's one thing to have
the technical chops yeah it's another
thing to be able to work in like a
co-working space or in your bedroom or
whatever yeah when you're in a different
time zone yeah I might get [ __ ] done
yeah yeah I mean I think I think there
are this one part which is the IQ which
is how good are you in all of these
different skills where do you need to
improve and the other part is EQ which
is what what your personality is we've
been doing some experiments or
partnerships with a couple of them but
we've not had a real breakthrough on
that yet but I do think that is going to
be that's gonna be helpful I mean the
reason I'm saying that is there are a
lot of companies who use hacker rank to
build out remote teams in India and
other parts of the globe there is a
company which probably found your
booking.com one of the most popular
travel companies in Amsterdam
they are able to hire developers all
over the globe using hacker and right
and and they're doing it in a very
efficient way because they understand
the skills strengths and weaknesses
before you come on site and before you
fly to Amsterdam so I think we're
starting to see this movement at least
happening in a lot of companies on the
IQ part of it and now if you can do a
better job or if you can work with a
partner or if you can do something even
internally at hacker going to do the EQ
it can be a very strong solution and so
this is all done through programmatic
exams there aren't any in person
interviews to like assess EQ there are
some companies who are working on this
programmatic way it sounds very
interesting I'm not
we've not like partnered with them
people really understand how how well
it'll fit in but it's certainly a very
very interesting opportunity okay so in
addition to maybe figuring that out in
the answer how else do you see paradigm
shifts happening for developing
developers in the future you know
obviously they'll be all over the world
yeah what else is gonna be happening and
you know five years I mean there are a
couple of things one is I think it was
there on Hacker News
it's the as much as there are api's and
different levels of abstraction that
have made it easier to get things
started to to set up your environment is
and and this is for somebody who's uh
who's a newbie who is just learning to
code it's very intimidating to to set up
something and and get it running in
compiler I mean you could have I think
that's one part where things needs to
get better you know here's an
environment here's where you can go
ahead and start start the code because a
lot of them give up oh yeah oh I I did
this thing online and then I tried it
out on my local it didn't work because I
don't know if you did you have this
library and there was a dependency
failure and you have to go and figure it
out and just becomes a big mess and you
give up so I think I think that that is
still you know we we still have to do a
better job if we have to increase the
number of developers in the world yeah
you can't have people giving up after
the third lesson or the fifth lesson and
saying you know it's not taking anywhere
and all
so there needs to be a purpose I mean
the purpose can't be you're gonna get a
hundred thousand dollar job right the
purpose has to be much more whatever is
in your mind you can go ahead and build
it on your own right I mean you have to
encourage the fact that you can build
versus I'm gonna get you a six-figure
salary to do it I think that's that's
one part that needs to get better if you
really have to create more developers in
the world well why does that have to get
better because $100,000 hour I mean I
agree with you yeah but to be devil's
advocate oh yes like that's a lot of
money to a lot of people yeah is that
not work I think it will work it will
work for a subset of people obviously
sure but I think you know in a very
longer-term the the really great
developers are people who did it not
because they'll get a job but because
they really wanted to build something
they really wanted to get this whatever
their the idea that they had in mind out
and I worry that if you had a and this
is just my hypothesis if you had a
monetary value associated with it you
might just focus a lot on that and and
you will reach a ceiling pretty soon
this is just my hypothesis versus if
you're if you really fall in love with
the idea of building or creating new
things
the ceiling is sort of infinite because
you can there's always new technologies
there are always new things that you can
go and build so it's more about what is
the type of behavior that you're trying
to create it's like a kid you're trying
to get into the developer world trying
to do it and what what is the type of
behavior that you're trying to create
and why you're doing what you're doing
so that that should be that should be
taken care and the second big bucket is
really the paradigm shift that I was
talking about which is more companies
should come forward and encourage and
say you know what we're about skills we
don't care about resumes we don't care
about what school did he go to as long
as you have the skills would be willing
to do I still think the proxy of your
GPAs and companies exists and a lot of
companies yeah absolutely i mean i think
that like people constantly disqualify
themselves before they even enter a race
yeah yeah and we see with YC all the
time like you know people are constantly
asking questions like you know i raise
money can I do YC
like I have a raise money can I do I see
yeah yeah I don't have a co-founder
gonna do I see yes and you often
encounter this thing where it's like you
can just apply yeah you just go for it
yeah and like moving things toward a
more meritocratic system yeah that makes
a huge difference yes what else does a
developer value in the hiring process
not just like about a company yeah what
do they want yeah I think the in the
contra intuitive thing at ease whenever
I've talked to a lot of companies is you
should also understand that developers
are interviewing you it's not just a
one-way thing and in it developers are
interviewing you know in a bunch of
different things right from the process
how tight and efficient are you are you
actually doing their peers and and also
the challenges or the questions that
you're asking and how deep sometimes
I've seen this at a lot of companies
people are scared to ask hard questions
because it might turn off it went the
other way which is I'm wondering is this
the level I mean if you just ask the
easy question oh here's our developers
that I'll be working on and of course
there's a different nuance to the hard
question right you don't want to ask a
complex math problem which has a trick
answer if you didn't know this
particular formula you can get it the
hard in the sense of relevant to the
business relevant to the relevant to the
job and how do you go about doing it
yeah the other thing that I'm starting
to see happen across a lot of different
companies and even hacker and has
incorporated this is the business acumen
the the level of business acumen that
you have as a developer usually it is
it's always developers or builders you
have this whatever requirements or spec
you can go ahead and do it but if you
look at a lot of the great companies who
will or Facebook or others they're all
developers at the heart of it right and
the reason of course they had great
products but they also had really strong
business acumen and really great
developers have that or what what I
think Steve Jobs incorporated is a 10x
developer have that level of very strong
business acumen so that's something that
people want to know what your strategy
is people want to know how they can
contribute how what they are building
helps in the business strategy often
times we think it's just about user
were using in amuse and and others but
no I'd like to know how we're building
the company and that's something that
we're trying to do a lot something that
you should do in the interview process
as well is my recommendation interesting
so in other words like ask questions
about product not just technical stuff
yeah and about the business strategy you
know you should you should be able to
challenge hacker rank or challenge the
company on you know why are you doing
this and here is a different idea here's
here's another thing that you can do
better
oh man now you're just dressing people
out like more stuff to prep it for yeah
but I think it's fun because I like it
yeah just sit in whatever like the
armchair critic you know you can say oh
why did you enter this geography I think
that's a bad move or why your business
plan edition is not as conflicting with
your free user in addition to me you can
have you can have a good conversation
and and frankly the the and here's I
mean all of these things are the nuances
are super important which is it doesn't
matter the the questions that the
candidate asks whether that's the right
or the wrong thing for the business you
have to judge the quality of thinking
right it could be completely off from
your business strategy that you would
actually implement because you have way
more data and you've been in this doing
this for six years or something on those
lines but it's the quality of thinking
and how do you what's the framework of
asking questions that you should be
judging people on okay and I found those
questions and developers really be at a
much higher productivity at our company
you know what about the the brain
teasers are they still in fashion
developers like them at all no I think I
think it's it's not be using that it's I
don't know who created that some company
created that clearly I have to go back
and look at the his it's probably like
McKinsey or something yeah could be
right it is um
I think I think the underlying
underlying goal is the right one which
is basically they are trying to think
about the computational thinking which
is I don't know how many tennis balls
will fit in a Boeing right four seven I
think they're trying to again this is
the question are they trying to figure
out the quality of your thinking how do
you think about it how do you what kind
of
what kind of data that you will analyze
or how do you how do you structure the
problem how do you break break it down
into subproblems and go ahead and do it
but I think there are better ways that
you can assess the computational
thinking or the problem-solving skills
we just interesting because that's what
the hiding managers care about the most
in a much more developer-friendly coding
friendly way of helping people do that
cool okay so in closing I'm curious
about your experience as a founder
hiring developers like we've handled
we've covered a bunch of stuff for like
if you're a company this is how you hire
you're like 1,000 and first developer
yeah but if it's just you your
co-founder and you raise a little bit of
money or you're you're making enough
money that you could finally hire
someone yeah what are the stuff what are
the things you're thinking about one of
the things you're testing for early on
yeah I think Peter Thiel talked about
this and I think maybe one of the
podcasts or one of the interviews which
is the way PayPal got built was they
went and hired people who who the others
thought weren't qualified but actually
they were really really good because
they didn't have the traditional degree
or the traditional background and doing
it I think the first 20 people or so at
PayPal were were very much on those
lines that's kind of how we at least
built the first five to ten hires of
developers and it's really helped us a
lot if you look at it I mean Holly and I
didn't go to the IITs which is the
equivalent of Stanford and you know the
first five to ten developers that we
hired we're people who were very smart
or very skilled and it's almost this
quote-unquote untapped pool and it's the
secret source and and then that really
set everything right from your
motivation and drive to do great things
I mean the first engineers are still
with our company and doing amazing
things actually and [ __ ] and they are
doing some great things right now
leading a team they're managing a team
and the motivation of the drive to do
really great things the ability to learn
the ability to assess making sure that
the peer or whoever is going to join the
companies as good or better than them
all of that has helped a lot and and I
feel that's a
that's an important thing that I come
back to this whole proxy thing yeah the
current ways of doing proxy on GPS and
degrees is bad and you have to figure
out your first send people almost from
the untapped pool I think it helps a lot
in your driving motivation for the long
term it's just my hypothesis but I just
have one data point from hacker right
yeah no I mean I agree with you but like
the short answer is that you have to do
the work to find the great people and
it's like in that arbitrage of you don't
have the right credentials yeah but you
have all the skills yeah
so you're worth yeah also I think the I
think that some level people should be
really passionate about the mission and
and you and again again the nuance comes
here right which is you can't expect
somebody to be more passionate than you
that that's never going to happen
but as long as they have a they have a
real feel or connect you know what we
need to solve this problem and here are
some other ways that you can actually do
it you know that's another thing that
you need to test the first and
developers also alright man well thanks
for coming on yeah thank you for having
me
you